[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend wer in Deutschland
lebt profitiert ja von vielen
Errungenschaften die das Grundgesetz mit
sich bringt
Meinungsfreiheit Pressefreiheit
Versammlungsfreiheit
Religionsfreiheit und auch die Wahrung
der Menschenrechte und so weiter das
auch bei uns nicht alles rund läuft ist
ja kein Geheimnis aber die
parlamentarische Demokratie die
individuelle Freiheit an sich sind bei
uns ein wertgeschätztes und hohes Gut
umso unverständlicher erscheint es dann
vielen das Wahlberechtigte Deutsch
Türken jemanden wählen der für all das
nicht steht und auch wirtschaftlich kann
Erdogan die Inflation liegt dabei über
40 Prozent nicht wirklich überzeugen und
doch ist eine Mehrheit derer die von
ihrer Stimme hier Gebrauch gemacht haben
von Erdogan überzeugt warum Susanna
santine hat am Tag nach der
Präsidentschaftswahl nicht über sondern
mit ihnen geredet
auch in Duisburg trieb es gestern Abend
tausende türkischstämmige Menschen auf
die Straßen in vielen deutschen Städten
feiern sie den Sieg von Präsident
Erdogan auch nach der Stichwahl ist klar
in Deutschland hat der türkische
Präsident mit rund 67 Prozent deutlich
mehr Unterstützer als in der Türkei die
Euphorie bei vielen grenzenlos
nachdem das Ergebnis dann klar war da
waren wir dann draußen auf den Straßen
die Türkei wird stärker und das ist auch
unser Ziel es gibt keinen besseren also
ich bin
der Welt spielt erster mache und wir
werden auch unsere Leben für ihn noch
fahren gar kein Problem
auffällig war auch gestern wieder dass
viele das Zeichen der türkischen
Faschisten der Grauen Wölfe zeigten
und das der islamistischen Bruderschaft
diesen religiösen und politischen
Extremismus schüre Präsident Erdogan
auch bei Türken in Deutschland sagen
Kritiker bei vielen genießt er einen
bedenklichen Personenkult
dank eines etablierten türkischen
Netzwerkes in Deutschland sagt
Politikwissenschaftler
ganz wichtig die AKP Propaganda in den
DITIB Moscheen aber auch in im Fernsehen
durch die sozialen Netzwerke wird hier
eine Propaganda betrieben und eine
informationsblase erzeugt Erdogan
versucht sich natürlich auch zu
inszenieren als der große starke Führer
der auch der dem Westen die Stirn bietet
und versteht noch nie wurde der
Wahlkampf in den fast 1000 Moscheen so
intensiv und gleichzeitig so unbemerkt
betrieben wie diesmal organisiert von
der türkischen AKP Lobby-Organisation
UID traten seit September bis kurz vor
der Wahl dutzende akpolitiker in die
Moscheen auf
oder wie dieser akp-mann bei der
uid-zentrale in Köln
alle auf Werbetour für Präsident Erdogan
dass diese Menschen die hier lange leben
nicht wirklich angekommen sind daran
gibt es angesichts solcher Bilder kaum
Zweifel den autokarten Erdogan sehen sie
nicht
eine Sache mit der unsere Politik sich
auch auseinandersetzen muss wie es sein
kann dass ein Erdogan aus Ankara so
einen Einfluss auf diese jungen Menschen
hat die hier geborene aufgewachsen sind
und wie als Gesellschaft und unsere
Politik nicht ansatzweise diese Menschen
für die liberalen Werte unserer
Demokratie gewinnen kann für weitere
fünf Jahre ist Präsident Erdogan nun
also im Amt bestätigt worden auf seine
Fans in Deutschland kann er sich weiter
verlassen
bundesagraminister Özdemir sieht in
autokorsus und Kundgebungen übrigens
kein feiern harmloser Anhänger sondern
ein Zitat nicht zu überhörende Absage an
unsere pluralistische Demokratie und
Zeugnis unsere Scheiterns unter ihnen er
forderte eine Zeitenwende in der
deutschen Türkei Politik eine politische
Wende in der Türkei wird es jedenfalls
erst einmal nicht geben Präsident recept
type Erdogan teilte nach dem Weißig
ordentlich gegen seine Gegner aus und
versprach zu dem seinen Anhängern ein
Jahrhundert der Türkei Anna heißt über
die Nachwehen nach der historischen
Stichwahl
ein kleines Spielchen am Abend dachte
sich Arif das Glück sei schließlich
heute auf seiner Seite wo doch sein
Präsident endlich bestätigt wurde
niemand hat so viel Macht mit Geld kann
man das nicht kaufen das ist Liebe pure
Liebe und Leidenschaft wer es fühlt der
fühlt es einfach
für die einen ist heute ein Freudentag
für andere der Beginn düsterer Zeiten es
war eines der Liebsten Wahlkampfthemen
des Präsidenten die einschwörung auf den
Kampf gegen LGBT
da wir an die Heiligkeit der Familie
glauben werden wir niemals Kompromisse
eingehen die Familie ist heilig unsere
Werte sind unumstößlich
immer wieder betont er er werde aktiv
gegen diese perversen Tendenzen vorgehen
sollte er wiedergewählt werden unterwegs
auf die asiatische Seite Verabredung mit
einem Mann der nun um sein Leben
fürchten muss Ismael ist schwul und
bekennt sich dazu
der Sieg von Erdogan ist wie ein
Massaker gegen uns besondere Angst
machen Ismael Erdogans neue Verbündete
die mit aller Härte gegen Andersdenken
nur vorgehen wollen da ist die
faschistische MHP die
kurdisch-islamistische hühnerpaar dazu
die islamistische Partei jeniden refer
die Wahlwerbung macht mit einem Bus auf
dem männliche Kandidaten mit Bild
gezeigt werden von der weiblichen
Kandidatin hingegen nur ein Schatten
seine Angst scheint begründet in der
Siegesrede am Vorabend putscht Erdogan
seine Anhänger regelrecht auf
Opfer kann LGBT in die AKP nein die MHP
unterwandern nein können Sie unsere
volksallianz unterwandern nein und
trotzdem sein Aufbegehren für ein freies
Leben aufgeben und das Land verlassen
will Ismael nicht
wir haben die Wahlen zwar verloren aber
doch an Stärke gewonnen während der
Gewinner Erdogan so schwach ist wie nie
seine Hoffnung setze er jetzt auf die
Kommunalwahlen die stehen nächstes Jahr
an denn aufgeben das sei nur etwas für
Feiglinge
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat Präsident
Erdogan am Telefon übrigens zur
Wiederwahl gratuliert und ihn zu einem
Antrittsbesuch nach Deutschland
eingeladen fünf weitere Jahre wird
Erdogan also die Türkei regieren Jörg
Brase für uns auch heute wieder in
Ankara Jörg was ist denn das Positive
daran
positiv naja systemtheoretisch
gesprochen ist das politische Stabilität
hätte killig da wo du gewonnen hätte er
präsidialdickret gegen das Parlament
regieren müssen denn bei den Parlament
zu Bayern hat ja bekanntlich Erdogans
Parteien Bündnis die Mehrheit bekommen
jetzt bleibt Erdogan Präsident und kann
weiter durchregieren es herrschen also
politisch stabile Verhältnisse also
stabile Verhältnisse nach innen was ist
mit außen der Präsident ist sicher
sicher dass der Westen die Türkei mehr
braucht als andersherum sagt er
jedenfalls gleichzeitig Sprache von
düsteren Mächten worauf muss ich denn
der besten gefasst machen
der Westen Behälter im Prinzip einen
unbequem aber irgendwie doch
brechenbaren Partner weil Erdogan macht
letztlich das was ihm am meisten nutzt
der braucht Europa als
Wirtschaftspartner er braucht deutsche
Investitionen er braucht deutsche
Touristen will aber gleichzeitig auch
mit allen anderen Geschäfte machen
erdogan ist kein idealoge kein Idealist
der ist macht Politiker und als er jetzt
im Wahlkampf die Stimmen brauchte hat es
gut hat es ihm geholfen dass er sich
gegen die NATO gestellt hat dass der
schwedensator Beitritt verhindert hat
jetzt ist der am Ziel er ist gewählt
worden jetzt kann man fast damit rechnen
dass die Türkei diese Blockade aufgibt
und das Schweden sehr bald NATO Mitglied
werden könnte vielleicht sogar schon im
Juli und womit müssen Erdogans Gegner
rechnen die befürchten ja dass er weiter
auf einen autoritären und
nationalistischen Politikstil setzt also
was würde das für die Gegner bedeuten
das hat ja gestern in seiner Rede ja
schon angedeutet als er sagte dass es
weiter politische Gefangene geben wird
dass zum Beispiel der kurdische
Politiker Sella hat ihn demmertasche
weiter im Gefängnis bleibt und die
Opposition und viele Oppositionelle
fürchten dass es eben noch mehr
Verhaftungen geben könnte noch mehr
politische Prozesse das Rede meinungs-
und Versammlungsfreiheit noch weiter
eingeschränkt werden und das was man
tendenziell ja auch im Moment schon
sieht wird es wahrscheinlich in Zukunft
noch mehr geben nämlich das noch mehr
Menschen die Türkei verlassen aus
politischen oder aus wirtschaftlichen
Gründen ja mit seinen harten Ansagen hat
Erdogan ja jetzt schon die
Kommunalwahlen nächstes Jahr im Blick
war so vielen Dank für die Einschätzung
und wir blicken jetzt nach Spanien das
Land erlebt eine
rechtsgerichteten zu Nami so formulierte
es dort ein Politiker der Ausgang der
regional und Kommunalwahlen bringt
jedenfalls Gundula Veränderungen
definitiv mit sich
überraschend hat Spaniens
Ministerpräsident Sanchez angekündigt
die Parlamentswahl vorzuziehen vom
Jahresende auf den 23 juli damit
reagiert er auf die zum Teil
verheerenden Stimmverluste für seine
Sozialdemokratische Partei bei den
regionalen Kommunalwahlen
unerwartet deutlich gewann in vielen
Städten die oppositionelle Konservative
Volkspartei in der Region Madrid
erzählte sie die absolute Mehrheit am 1
Juli übernimmt Spanien turnusgemäß die
Ratspräsidentschaft der EU
den weltweiten Kampf gegen Plastikmüll
wollen die Vereinten Nationen mit einer
weiteren Verhandlungsrunde in Paris
voranbringen
plastikverschmutzung ersticke unsere
Ökosysteme so die Warnung der UN sie
arbeitet an verbindlichen Regeln für
einen globales Abkommen diskutiert wird
auch ein Verbot von
einwegplastikprodukten viele Staaten
setzen aber eher auf Recycling und
nachhaltige Alternativen
im Norden des Kosovo hat die NATO
geführte Schutztruppe K vor Proteste
militanter Serben gewaltsam aufgelöst
dabei wurden 25k vor Soldaten verletzt
seit Tagen gibt es dort immer wieder
Zusammenstöße zwischen der kosovarischen
Polizei und Serben die die Erfolge
ethnischer Albaner bei den
Kommunalwahlen vom April nicht
akzeptieren das Kosovo und Serbien sind
seit langem verfeindet
in Italien sind bei einem Bootsunglück
auf dem Lago Maggiore vier Menschen ums
Leben gekommen gestern Abend war das
Touristenboot während eines plötzlich
auftretenden Unwetters mit heftigen
Windböen gekennt hat insgesamt waren 23
Menschen an Bord 19 wurden gerettet oder
schwammen selbst an Land Deutsche waren
nicht an Bord gewesen
Russland ist aus dem KSE
Abrüstungsvertrag über konventionelle
Streitkräfte in Europa ausgetreten
Staatschef putin hatte das Gesetz Mitte
Mai vom Parlament beschließen lassen
jetzt wurde es veröffentlicht der KSI
Vertrag regelt seit 1990 Obergrenzen für
etwa Kampfpanzer und schwere Artillerie
Moskau hatte sich schon seit 2007 nicht
mehr daran gehalten
der russische Präsident Putin hat also
den Austritt aus dem Abrüstungsvertrag
vollzogen gleichzeitig überzieht sein
Militär die Ukraine weiter mit
Luftangriffen in der Regel finden diese
Nacht statt doch nun gab es seit langem
auch wieder Angriffe am hellichten Tag
insbesondere auf die ukrainische
Hauptstadt vermögend für die Menschen
berichtet Tim Krüger
die ukrainische Luftabwehr rund um Kiew
heute Mittag in voller Aktion denn an
diesem Tag kommen die russischen Raketen
und Drohnen nicht nur in der Nacht
sie terrorisieren die Menschen in Kiew
während sie ihrem Alltag nachgehen
10.000 besuchen Schutz in den
U-Bahn-Stationen der ukrainischen
Hauptstadt
ich sah 6 7 8 eine ganze Reihe von
Explosionen am Himmel deswegen bin ich
mit meinen Kollegen hierhergekommen
draußen kann es wegen der Trümmer
gefährlich werden deshalb habe ich keine
andere Wahl
damit können sie uns nicht brechen ich
bin dankbar dass es die U-Bahn und
unsere Flugabwehr gibt alles wird gut
seit Wochen schon vor allem nachts das
gleiche zermürbende Spektakel am Himmel
über Kiel die ukrainische Flugabwehr
versucht russische Raketen und Drohnen
abzuschießen
es sind Soldaten wie Alexander der seit
Anfang des Krieges mit seinem
stinger-system im Einsatz ist immer auf
Standby um die Menschen in der Ukraine
zu schützen
jetzt schon wenn sie uns auf diese Art
und Weise zermürben wollen um die
Flugabwehr von Kiew zu schwächen dann
werden sie das nicht schaffen denn wir
sind standhaft
die Flugabwehr verhindere immer öfter
das Raketen und Drohnen ihr Ziel
erreichen sagt Alexander
am Anfang des Krieges war unsere
Flugabwehr zwei effizient aber lange
nicht so gut wie jetzt
mittlerweile schützen wir Kiew
garantiert zu 95%
[Musik]
je mehr solche Systeme wir haben desto
mehr Städte kritische Infrastrukturen
wichtige strategische Objekte können wir
verteidigen noch nie seit Kriegsbeginn
hat Russland mit so vielen Raketen und
Drohnen die Ukraine angegriffen wie in
diesem mai Moskau versucht ganz offenbar
die Ukraine
der Tod meiner Kinder soll uns dafür
öffnen Freunde zu werden dieser Satz ist
auch 30 Jahre nach dem Brandanschlag von
Solingen so groß so versöhnlich so
zugewandt und Ring zurecht vielen immer
noch Respekt abgesagt hat ihn mir würde
gerne die damals bei einem der
schlimmsten rassistischen Verbrechen in
Deutschland fünf Familienmitglieder
verlor Hass hat sie abgelehnt denn der
würde nur den Tod bringen und doch zog
und zieht sich der rechtsextreme Hass
weiter durch unsere Gesellschaft und so
war der Gedenktag heute mehr als eine
Mahnung er war auch eine Ermahnung an
den Staat und an alle Demokraten und
demokratenen nicht wegzuschauen und
Gesicht zu zeigen
stilles Gedenken am Vormittag an dem Ort
an dem einmal das Haus der Familie
Gensch stand auch Angehörige sind
gekommen an diesem jahres-tag die Stadt
will damit die Erinnerung an den
rassistischen Brandanschlag wachhalten
das kann überall passieren und auch
heute wieder deswegen müssen wir sehr
sensibel sein und daran benutzt ihre
Jahrestag auch erinnern das ist
ein sehr
Herzen definitiv getroffen es ist der 29
mai 1993 fünf Mädchen und Frauen liegen
nachts oben unterm Dach in ihren Betten
als Junge rechtsradikale unten den Flur
anzünden das Haus brennt fast komplett
aus ging das Feuer und den Rauch haben
sie keine Chance Bürste insche Gülistan
Öztürk Hatice seine und Julia Gensch
Ministerpräsident rau damals vor Ort
fassungslos
eines der schrecklichsten geschehen
dass ich in meiner bisherigen
verantwortungszeit erlebt habe
es ist der bis dahin schwerste
rassistische Anschlag auf Asylbewerber
und Migranten in Deutschland
anderthalb Jahre später stehen vier
junge Männer aus der Solinger
neonazis-szene vor Gericht beim Prozess
bekommen Sie alle die jeweilige
Höchststrafe die haben sie inzwischen
abgesessen
am Nachmittag in Solingen
ein Moment der Stille bei der zentralen
Gedenkveranstaltung
man müsse als Staat wachsam sein Marthe
Bundespräsident Frank Walter Steinmeier
und dieser Rechte Terror ist
verantwortlich für die Toten hier in
Solingen diesen rechten Terror gab es
vor Solingen es gibt den nach Solingen
es gibt eine Kontinuität von
rechtsextremer Gewalt in unserem Land
ein zentraler Platz trägt jetzt den
Namen von mehrflüge Gensch sie hatte bei
dem Anschlag fünf Angehörige verloren
und sich danach immer für Versöhnung
eingesetzt sie starb vor sieben Monaten
stellvertretend für die gesamte Familie
ergriff heute ihre Enkelin das Wort die
ganze Gesellschaft sei gefordert
darstellen ob nicht das Problem die
Laute Minderheit ist die das falsche
verbreitet sondern vielmehr die
schweigende Mehrheit die nicht in der
Lage ist das Richtige zu sagen
der Herzenswunsch der Familie sein
Museum an der Stelle an der einmal das
Haus stand damit die Erinnerungen an den
Brandanschlag vor 30 Jahren nie
verblasst
der Krebsforscher und
medizin-nobelpreisträger Harald zur
Hausen ist im Alter von 87 Jahren
gestorben der international bekannte
Virologe galt als geistiger Vater eines
Impfstoffs gegen
Gebärmutterhalskrebs zu Hause leitete 20
Jahre lang das Krebsforschungszentrum in
Heidelberg bis ins hohe Alter forschte
er zur Rolle von Virusinfektionen bei
Krebserkrankungen vielfach wurde zu
Hause ausgezeichnet
2008 mit dem Medizin Nobelpreis
Glückwünsche prasselten heute auf die
Eishockey-Nationalmannschaft ein von
Bundeskanzler und bundesinnenministerin
und vielen Fans am Münchner Flughafen
die Vize Weltmeister hatten im Finale
gegen Rekord Weltmeister Kanada verloren
mit Silber aber die erste WM-Medaille
seit 70 Jahren gewonnen jetzt freut sich
die Eishockey Welt auf die Heim WM 2027
großer Jubel auch in Heidenheim nachdem
der erste FC des 50.000 Einwohner
Städtchens auf der württembergischen
Ostalb den Aufstieg in die
Fußball-Bundesliga geschafft hat wurde
heute gefeiert in der 9 Minute der
Nachspielzeit hatte Heidenheim gestern
gegen Jahn Regensburg den Aufstieg und
Platz 1 in der zweiten Liga perfekt
gemacht
zähle noch die Wetteraussichten die
sommerlich bleiben auch morgen ist es
meist sonnig nur im Nordwesten bewölkt
und nur örtlich gibt es etwas Regen am
Nachmittag im Südosten vereinzelt
Gewitter 14 Grad an der Nordsee und bis
26 Grad am Oberrhein auch in den
nächsten Tagen viel Sonne und höchstens
an den Alpen mal eingewitter an der See
nur um 15 Grad im Südwesten bis zu 29
Grad warm
wir haben keine 9 Minuten Nachspielzeit
das war's von uns für heute wir sagen
auf Wiedersehen und bis morgen machen
sie es gut wo auch immer sie sind
tschüss
[Musik]